this episode is brought to you by Maui
Nui venison wildly delicious Venice and
Maui Nui is one of my favorite things on
the entire planet it has been for quite
a while I've been eating Maui Nui
venison for now the past three plus
years and there's no going back my
pantry and freezers are full of it I
restock every month why would I do this
one if I combine Maui Nui venison with
even a little exercise I drop body fat
unbelievably quickly and axis deer have
roughly two percent body fat it's
incredibly lean two it's very tender not
gamey at all tastes delicious and it's
one of the most nutrient dense Meats on
the planet I would go so far as to say
it is the most nutrient dense meat I
have ever found because of the rich
volcanic soils remarkable plant
diversity and so on including wild
grazing so I literally 10 minutes ago
just finished eating some leftovers of
ground Axis deer this is Maui Nui
venison with some canned chili just
organic chili beans and so on that I put
into a pan and cooked for 10 minutes and
I would rather eat that than a 500 meal
in New York City honestly it makes me
happier on a deep level to eat this and
it makes me healthier on a fundamental
level so number three ethically I feel
great about Maui Nui protein access deer
are an invasive species on Maui where
their population needs to be managed in
order to protect vulnerable ecosystems I
think the number that was introduced
while I was perhaps maybe six deer in
1959 something like that and unmanaged
that population could grow to I think
it's 200 000 within the next 20 years so
using stress-free harvesting methods
Maui Nui prevents environmental
destruction caused by access to your
overpopulation which literally looks
like wildfire damage from helicopter so
so back to the story I love this stuff
that much should be clear I eat it all
the time I use their dog treats for
Molly I use their broth which is second
to none in terms of nutritional profile
Maui nui's fresh venison is a nearly
daily go-to for me both as a supplement
to my daily diet that's broth jerks
snacks Etc that I mentioned and through
main courses like last night via their
fresh meat subscription program and the
cuts are all spectacular leg medallions
are one of my favorites I fell in love
with this company so much and the
husband and wife co-founders behind it
that I ended up investing and that is a
huge Rarity especially with this type of
company remarkably Maui Nui has now
nearly stabilized Maui's access to your
population that's been the goal all
along which means the door to one of the
most exclusive proteins on the market
will soon be closed the list of people
waiting for invitations to become a
fresh subscriber is long that's not BS
that is the case there's a long wait
list which is why I am very excited to
offer you guys my listeners Tim Ferriss
show listeners an exclusive opportunity
to bypass the waitlist to cut the line
and get instant access to one of the few
remaining subscriptions you can secure
your subscription by visiting Maui news
venison.com Tim that's Maui
m-a-u-i-n-u-i-nui venison.com Tim you
need to have the slash Tim to bypass the
line if you're already on the wait list
and you go to this link you will get
immediate access so mauinui venison.com
Maui Nui must stop offering
subscriptions at only 8 000 subscribers
when the access to your population will
have reached equilibrium so you must act
fast to grab one of the remaining spots
so subscribe today at Maui news
venison.com Tim one more time that's
Maui Nui venison.com Tim and the race
goes to the Swift
foreign
this episode is brought to you by eight
sleep my God am I in love with AIDS
sleep good sleep is the Ultimate Game
Changer more than 30 percent of
Americans struggle asleep and I'm a
member of that sad group temperature is
one of the main causes of poor sleep and
heat has always been my Nemesis I've
suffered for decades tossing and turning
throwing blankets off putting them back
on and repeating Ad nauseam but now I am
falling asleep in record time faster
than ever why because I'm using a simple
device called the Pod Pro cover by eight
sleep it's the easiest and fastest way
to sleep at the perfect temperature it
pairs Dynamic cooling and heating with
biometric tracking to offer the most
advanced but most user-friendly Solution
on the market I pulled all of you guys
on social media about the best tools for
Sleep enhancing sleep and eight sleep
was by far and away the crowd favorite I
mean people were just raving fans of
this so I used it and here we are add
the Pod Pro cover to your current
mattress and start sleeping as cool as
55 degrees Fahrenheit or as hot as 110
degrees Fahrenheit it also splits your
bed in half so your partner can choose a
totally different temperature my
girlfriend runs hot all the time she
doesn't need cooling she loves the Heat
and we can have our own bespoke
temperatures on either side which is
exactly what we're doing now for me and
for many people the result eight sleep
users fall asleep up to 32 percent
faster reduce sleep interruptions by up
to 40 and get more restful sleep overall
I can personally attest to this because
I track it in all sorts of ways it's the
total solution for enhanced recovery so
you can take on the next day feeling
refreshed and good news eight sleep has
launched the next generation of the Pod
the new pod 3 enables more accurate
sleep and health tracking with twice the
number of sensors it's just a smoother
better experience that delivers you the
best sleep on Earth at least that has
been true for me simply add this to your
existing mattress and you're all set it
is not magic but sometimes it does feel
like it it just works so go to
atesleep.com Tim and save 250 on the Pod
cover that's eightsleep.com Tim all
spelled out
e-i-g-h-t-hsleep.com Tim eight sleep
currently ships within the US Canada the
UK select countries in the EU and
Australia you can also find the link in
this episode's description
at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hand starts
shaking can I answer your personal
questions
[Music]
endoskeletons
[Music]
[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferriss welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show where it
is usually my job to deconstruct
world-class performers to tease out
their routines habits Etc that you can
apply to your own life and lives this
episode is something different it's an
experimental format that I am super
excited about and apparently so are many
of you it's backed by popular demand
this is an episode that scratches an
itch I've had for many years now I'm not
always able to listen to every great
podcast episode out there even when they
are by some of my closest friends to
answer that predicament I decided to ask
them many of my friends to send a top
segment from their own podcast
podcasts that I could listen to and more
importantly also share with you my dear
listeners my team edited them together
and here we are this episode is a
compilation of roughly 15 to 30 minute
clips from some of the best podcasters
and also best interviewees in the world
and certainly some of my favorites at
the beginning of each clip you will hear
an intro from the host and where to find
their work and podcast at the end I'll
also share one or two of my favorite
clips from episodes of the Tim Ferriss
show you can view this episode as a
buffet and I strongly suggest that you
check out the shows included if you like
my podcast you will very likely enjoy
the featured shows in this episode for
the full list of the guests featured
today see the episode's description or
as usual head to tim.blog podcast for
all the details and before you go
do you like this format please let me
know on Twitter at T Ferris
t-f-e-r-r-i-s-s and also mention CC at
Team Tim Ferriss if you remember without
further Ado please enjoy
foreign
friends
I'm Tara Brock and I've been teaching
meditation primarily from the Buddhist
tradition for about 45 years and I spent
about 20 of those years as a clinical
psychologist I'm also author of several
books including radical acceptance and
trusting the gold
my weekly podcast of talks and guided
meditations which goes by my name draws
on Buddhism psychology and Science and
we explore everything from how to work
with self-judgments fears trauma losses
to how to resolve conflicts and increase
intimacy with each other to how in these
times of such Global trauma and
dividedness we can be part of a larger
societal healing
and in the deepest way the weekly talks
are guides to realizing who we are
beyond the story of a separate and often
deficient self realizing the love and
the creativity and awareness that
expresses our true nature
in addition to the podcast I lead a
mindfulness teacher training program
with my colleague Jack cornfield that is
thousands of participants from over 50
countries all dedicated to teaching
others the practices of mindfulness and
compassion
so friends I hope you'll visit my
website it's tarabrock.com to find
information about all my offerings
including an upcoming introductory
course to meditation links to the books
and you'll find hundreds of free talks
and guided meditations and other
resources
foreign
a good number of years ago now the Dalai
Lama was interviewed by Network news and
the inquiry was really about happiness
because that was the subject of his
latest book and they asked him a
question which was what was your
happiest moment in memory and his
response he first gave that kind of now
classic mischievous look and his
response was I think now
I've always loved that story because you
know for many listening being present
here and now is not a new idea and yet
as we know often it's mostly an idea you
know we're usually on our way somewhere
we're usually checking things off the
list
so often we're lost in thought and and
thinking that the important moment of
our life is we're on our way to it or
it's already in the past but it's rare
that we stand so right now this moment
really matters
the gift of meditation
of training
in present is that it really allows our
body and mind to be in the same place at
the same time
it allows us to arrive in the one place
where love and happiness and creativity
and healing Freedom all is possible
so our inquiry really is what takes us
from presence and if we begin to look
we're in a trance of thinking most of
the time and that trance is typically
driven by wants and fears by the sense
that something's missing right now
are something's wrong
and even under that it's often and this
is usually our core Focus it's
something's wrong with me
with how I am with what I'm doing that
sense of never enough that I'm in some
way deficient or flawed and that
failures around the corner
and the expression of that is a
background sense of of fear or anxiety
and uncomfortableness and sometimes
shame
so this will be our our subject for this
talk which is how do we wake up out of
this trance of feeling like there's
something wrong with us
how do we
disentangle from the self-judgments and
and live our lives and one of these
stories I'll always remember a woman
describe being with her mom when her mom
was dying and she was in a coma and at
one moment her mother kind of woke up
from the coma and was very lucid and
looked her in the eyes and said you know
all my life I thought something was
wrong with me
and those were her last words
and for this woman in a sense it was a a
kind of a gift because
it made so clear how we can go through
decades
how many moments we miss of living
of loving of enjoying Beauty
when we're all wrapped up in thinking
that we need to be different
that we're falling short in some way
and this is what drew me to write my
first book radical acceptance
as a response to that sense of being
flawed being caught in what I call the
trance of unworthiness
I remember after writing the book I was
on book tour and one stop I was giving a
workshop on this and there was a big
poster of me and the caption at the
bottom was something is wrong with me
it was a great welcome to a new
community there
um and yet you know for those of you
listening if you start looking at your
life most of you know I mean huge amount
of self-judgment
and what we don't always realize and
this is why I call it a trance
is how much that underlying sense of not
enough
affects our moments affects how
generative and creative we are at work
affects our relationships how intimate
we can be because it's very hard to be
close to others if we feel something's
wrong with us
it affects everything and the Buddha
said that the great suffering we
experience
is not realizing the truth of who we are
our true nature and being caught up in a
in an identification with a small
limited self
and there's a story I've always loved
that I think describes this so
beautifully true story that there was a
enormous clay statue of the Buddha in
Thailand and it wasn't beautiful but it
was loved and revered by the populations
that had survived over centuries of
Storms and battles and so on
and in the 50s there was a long dry
season and during that time there were
some cracks appeared so an enterprising
monk shined a flashlight into the crack
and what came back was The Gleam of gold
and shined into another crack and
another and they took off what turned
out to be just a covering of plaster and
clay and found the largest solid gold
statue of the Buddha in that part of
Asia
and what's interesting is the monks say
that the statue was covered to protect
it during tumultuous times
and it's much in the same way
that we protect our innate goodness and
Purity we cover it over when we feel
threatened to be able to navigate our
world
and the suffering is when we cover over
with our defenses and our aggressions
and so on is that we get identified with
the covering
we think we're the covering
that controlling promoting self
and we forget who's looking through
we forget the the tender away cart the
awareness that's looking through
you know the essence of all sickness is
homesickness
there's a suffering when we forget the
gold when we leave home
we forget what we really belong to that
aliveness and awareness and loving we
forget Who We Are
it becomes such a profound inquiry you
know what
leads us to forgetting who we are to
judging ourselves so harshly to becoming
so identified with the coverings
and really we can look first to main
culprit the messaging of our culture
our culture tells us what it means to be
a respectable person a successful person
a likable person
primary funnel for our messages that
trap us in the trance of unworthiness is
through family and caregivers of course
this is the domain of most Psychotherapy
it's a primary channel for the culture
of insecurity and fear of failure I mean
if you could ask
what a child most wants what a child a
young child most wants and needs
it's to be understood and loved
yet out of their own insecurities and
fears most parents don't know how to see
clearly and mirror back who this child
is most parents aren't equipped to love
unconditionally
so for so many there's an experience of
severed belonging
cut off from the most significant other
and really suffered belonging from the
not okay parts of ourselves I mean the
core wound
I'm not lovable I'm not loved I'm not
worthy
this is the trance of unworthiness
the healing
the path to
realizing who we are and living from
that freedom
in terms of the trainings of meditation
is learning to bring radical acceptance
an unconditional compassionate presence
to the experience of the moment
this is what helps to dissolve the
coverings to make the coverings
transparent so our light our creativity
our love our intelligence can shine
through
foreign
radical acceptance really opening to the
present moment but I want to note here
the objection most people have a fear of
accepting how we are in the moment our
fears our shame
and the fear is I'll never change I'll
never get better
and yet as American psychologist Carl
Rogers put it it wasn't until I accepted
myself just as I was that I was free to
change
in other words the prerequisite for True
transformation and healing is this
radical acceptance this presence and
kindness with what's right here
so the rest of this exploration is how
do we do that
and what I'd like to do here is
introduce a practice a meditation that
weaves together mindfulness a mindful
presence with self-compassion that can
really free our hearts that can wake us
up from the coverings and allow us to
rest and express the gold of who we are
and the meditation is called the rain
meditation I know many are familiar with
it rains an acronym for recognize allow
investigate and nurture
recognize meaning see what's here okay
fear just name it name it allow allow it
to be here not to fight it not to judge
it just let be
investigate
that doesn't mean cognitively
investigate that can be a trap it means
investigate by deepening the inquiry
into the body and feeling what's here
contacting it
and then nurture the last part of rain
is to bring kindness to what we find
when we do that we experience what's
called after the rain which means we
start opening to our natural being to
the gold that's here to the awareness
and love that was here but covered over
rain allows us to change very
deep-rooted patterning
during the pandemic I had countless
emails people saying rain saved my life
and I really understood uh what they
meant it's had such an impact on me
I remember when my mother first moved
down to live with my husband and me
and she was 82. and she had a lot that
she needed from me a lot of a doctor's
appointments and mostly just needed me
to keep her company some and at the same
time I had a whole lot going on on the
work and teaching front and I started
feeling increasingly stressed and I
remember one day being at the computer
and put I was writing a talk it was on
loving kindness she walked into my
office to show me an article and I
barely looked up from the screen and so
she very graciously put it down and and
laughed and as I kind of looked up to
see her retreating form I had this
thought I don't know how long I'll have
her
so I decided to do the practice of rain
and got quiet and the r
recognized was a feeling a sense of you
know guilt and anxiety
you know I'm just not coming through and
the a allow I just let that be there
rather than adding more judgment to it
and the allow has this sense of
this is this belongs just like the waves
in the ocean this this belongs it's
really letting it be and that allowed me
to deepen my attention and begin to
investigate
and I started feeling the feelings in my
body the tightness and I asked myself
what am I believing and the belief was
I'm failing I'm feeling my mother and
I'm also going to fall short teaching
the feelings in my body were a real
squeeze in my heart and this this sense
of pressure and tightness
and as I opened to it I asked the
question that really deepens
investigation which is what do I need
what is this vulnerable place need this
place of of feeling you know squeezed
and guilty and fearful
and what I got was I just need to trust
I need to trust my love I need to trust
my goodness my heart you know and so I
put my hand in my heart and this is a
part of nurturing it often it makes it
even more powerful and I just gave
myself that message you know trust your
heart trust your goodness it's okay
and as I did that I just felt more space
felt more space more openness and so I
stayed for a few moments and rested in a
more spacious more tender awareness
that's f after the rain you know there
was a shift I I went from this being
this you know guilty anxious person
to the space of compassion of kindness
and what I noticed in the days and weeks
to come and I repeated rain I did what I
call a light rain just I repeated it and
it was shorter and very effective
because I noticed when I was with my mom
I was able to be really present I was
able to really be with her and enjoy our
big salads for dinner and our walks by
the river
and when she died it was a few years
later three or four years later
um
deep grief of course I I adored her
but no regrets and I realized that rain
saved my life moments
with my mom
when I did the rain practice I put my
hand on my heart I gave myself a message
and that's often a beautiful way of
self-compassion to give ourselves a
message that will bring some comfort and
healing but sometimes we can't and I
want a name here that self-compassion
doesn't mean that we're offering
ourselves compassion that the self is
offering yourself compassion you can
draw on a larger source
um I worked with an a vet who came back
after being in Iraq
and when we explored what would help him
nurture a very very uh traumatized place
in him it was the love of Jesus
a man described being with the Dalai
Lama and telling the Dalai Lama about
his fears in the Dalai Lama said you
know just let yourself be held in the
heart of the Buddha
and a physicist I was reading talks
about touching a tree and feeling the
nurturing there or the connection
you can call on a friend you can call on
a deity you can call on your ancestors I
sometimes call on formless loving
awareness some larger source
what rain does when we offer ourselves
attention and when we bring in that
nurturing is a kind of spiritual
re-parenting
we're bringing the presence and kindness
we need to heal
and if you're more you know science
oriented you might think of it that
we're actually rewiring the brain with
rain because it creates new neuronal
Pathways to feeling empowered creative
loving lucid
okay friends let's do a brief practice
we'll do what I call a light rain to
give you a taste of it and wherever you
are you might adjust how you're sitting
so you can just know you're feeling
comfortable at ease
awake
you might take a few full breaths
letting your eyes close or your gaze be
downcast
and you might bring to mind a situation
in your life
where you turn on yourself in some way
it might be in a relationship
might be at work
might be related to an addiction
[Music]
to a Health Challenge
but somewhere some situation
where
you land up feeling judgmental
and down on yourself
Let Yourself Go to the most triggering
moment of that
and we begin a light rain by recognizing
what's going on
and you might just mentally whisper the
word that most captures what's going on
it might be judgment
shame embarrassment fear anxiety anger
and then allow it
and that means in some way you're saying
this belongs this is part of
the experience of the moment
letting it be
and beginning to investigate it you know
what am I believing when this is going
on
am I believing that I'm failing
that I'm flawed
that I'm creating pain
for myself or for another
and with whatever I'm believing watch
the strongest feeling in the body going
on
you might feel your throat your chest
your belly and just sense where you feel
vulnerability where you feel tightness
or activation
and you might even let your face and
your posture Express what you're feeling
it's a powerful way to get more
somatically connected
and continue to investigate and feel
right into the center of the
vulnerability
and ask yourself what do I need
you know how does this part want me to
be with it
and explore nurturing
you might put your hand on your heart
especially if you've never done it vary
the touch so it expresses kindness
and to send some message inward that you
think might be healing could be I care
about the suffering
or trust your heart trust your goodness
or I'm here and I'm not leaving
or it's okay you're enough
whatever you sense
will bring
some healing and you can have it come
from an outside source
a friend a grandparent your dog
the trees
a deity
formless
loving awareness
let that energy of kindness move through
your hand right into your heart to
wherever you feel vulnerable
and then let go of all doings and sense
the presence that's here
sense the shift from a flawed self to
the the awakeness the awareness the
tenderness noticing the gold
noticing this tender presence that's
more the truth of who you are than any
limiting story or belief
more you trust this the more freedom
creativity love aliveness you'll find in
your life
and take a few full breaths
if your eyes are closed opening your
eyes and the last part I've been
focusing on inner healing and as we hold
our own being with radical acceptance as
we practice rain and come home into who
we are that loving presence naturally
extends to others we're able to see
their vulnerability and see their goal
and I've worked with so many parents
been reactive with their children and
done a kind of inner rain process and
much more able to to see and respond to
their children's unmet needs less
judgmental
no and if work with so many people who
are in conflict with Partners other
people in their life and that inner work
enables us to put down blame and really
communicate in a much more intelligent
open-hearted way
and it takes practice
we go into trance we disconnect from our
own loving away cart in gold and then
we're really looking through the filters
of our culture our society we don't see
others we we see their coverings
if we're in our ego identify with our
ego that's what we see in others
so I'll share a final story that's been
a real guide for me on the path
and this story is told by a minister
describing a family holiday trip and
stopping at a restaurant that's nearly
empty and she says she sat her son Eric
her one-year-old in a high chair and
suddenly she hears him squeal with Glee
hi there two words you thinks are one hi
there his face is alive with excitement
then she says I saw the source of his
merriment and my eyes could not take it
in all at once a tattered rag of a coat
baggy pants gums as barrows Eric's hair
uncombed unwashed his hands were
flapping in the air around loose wrists
hi there baby hi there big boy I see you
Buster my husband and I exchanged the
look that was a cross between what do we
do and poor devil error continued to
laugh and answer hi there every call was
echoed this old geezer was creating a
nuisance with my beautiful baby I shoved
a cracker at Eric and he pulverized it
in the tray I whispered why me our meal
came and the nuisance continued now the
old bum was shouting do you know patty
cake attaboy you know peek-a-boo Halo
kinos peekaboo wait and silence except
Eric who was running through his
repertoire for the admiring Applause of
a skid row bum we had enough Dennis went
to pay the check imploring me to get
Eric and meet me in the parking lot
I trundled Eric out of the high chair
and looked toward the exit the old man
sat poised and waiting his chair
directly between me and the door
Lord just let me out of here before he
speaks to me or Eric I headed toward the
door
it soon became apparent that both the
Lord and Eric had other plans as I drew
closer to the man Eric had his eyes
riveted to his best friend leaned far
over my arm reaching with both arms and
a baby pick me up position in a split
second of balancing my baby and turning
to counter his weight I came eye to eye
with the old man Eric was lunging for
him arms spread wide the bum's eyes both
asked and implored would you let me hold
your baby
there was no need for me to answer since
Eric propelled himself from my arms to
the mans
suddenly a very old man and a very young
baby were involved in a love
relationship Eric laid his tiny head
upon the man's ragged shoulder the Man's
eyes closed and I saw tears hover
beneath his lashes his aged hands full
of grime and pain and hard labor gently
so gently cradled my baby's bottom and
stroked his back I stood awestruck the
old man rocked and cradled Eric in his
arms for a moment and then his eyes
opened and sat squarely on mine he said
in a firm commanding voice you take care
of this baby somehow I managed I will
from a throat that contained a stone he
pried Eric from his chest unwillingly
longingly as though he was in pain I
held my arms open to receive my baby and
again the gentleman addressed me
God bless you ma'am you've given me my
Christmas gift
I said nothing more than a muttered
thanks with Eric back in my arms I ran
for the car
Dennis wondered why I was crying and
holding Eric so tightly and why I was
saying my God my God forgive me
I've shared this story many times and
each time it feels like a wake up
you know we think society's thoughts we
forget to look past the coverings
towards the human heart
and in our current world friends
where there's so much dividedness and
Trauma
seeing others as different as bad as
inferior
create such violence
there's so much trance one of the great
gifts we bring to the world
is the dedication to see the gold in
ourselves and in each other and that's
the meaning of Namaste now I see the
sacred in you
it allows us to be part of the healing
it allows us to bridge divides and and
bring forward the goodness the potential
you know this capacity to see gold is
the blessing of radical acceptance
of learning to meet our moments with
open-hearted presence
it lets us truly live from Love
I'd like to close with a
short prayer this is written by the poet
Diane Ackerman
you might sit back and close your eyes
and just take it in
in the name of Daybreak and the eyelids
of mourning and the wayfaring moon and
the night when it departs
I swear I will not dishonor my soul with
hatred
but offer myself humbly as a guardian of
nature
as a Healer of misery
as a messenger of wonder
as an architect of peace
in the name of the Sun and its mirrors
and the crowning seasons of the Firefly
and the Apple
I will honor all life wherever and in
whatever form it may dwell
on Earth my home and in the Mansions of
the Stars
thank you for your attention friends
blessings
hi I'm Ryan Holliday the author of 13
best-selling books and the creator of
the daily stoic in this episode I'm
going to break down some of the most
important questions that I've gathered
from some of the wisest philosophers
most incisive thinkers greatest leaders
and most awesome badasses that have ever
lived the concept was actually inspired
by something that Tim taught me Tim's
love of asking questions which change
how you think about things these
particular questions that a big
influence on my life and career also you
can check out my new book discipline is
Destiny the power of self-control which
is out now and you can buy anywhere
books or sold you can also buy a signed
copy from me in the daily Stoke store at
dailystoke.com or in person in my
bookstore the painted porch here in
Bastrop Texas
foreign
who are you spending time with gercher
says show me who you spend time with and
I will tell you who you are Seneca talks
about spending time with people who make
you a better person my dad said to me as
a kid you become like her friends well
the question is are you spending time
with people who are averaging you
towards where you want to go are they
averaging you away from where you want
to go this is a question that can lead
to some hard decisions people that
you're going to spend less time with who
are you seeing after work who are you
reading who are you talking to the
people we spend time with are either
going to make us better they're going to
make us worse or they're going to keep
us exactly who we are which is either a
good thing or a very bad thing is this
in my control Epictetus says this is the
key question this is the chief task of
the philosopher in life which is
separating the things that are up to us
and the things that are not up to us and
so much of the time and energy we spend
in this life are on things that are not
up to us that are not in our control it
just started raining I don't need to
have an opinion on the fact that it's
raining because it's not in my control
but what is in my control is what I'm
going to do what's in our control is our
actions our thoughts our opinions and so
stoic learns to tune out what's not in
our control and it focuses on what is in
our control and so we ask ourselves
about everything we experience
everything we're feeling everything
we're working on is this up to me or am
I throwing good energy after bad am I
beating myself against a wall that's
never going to move what does your ideal
day look like a life Seneca says is made
up of days Annie Dillard said how we
spend our lives is of course how we
spend our days what does an ideal day
look like for you how are you trying to
design your life if you don't know what
a good day is like what your ideal is
then you're just going to be working on
making more money acquiring more Fame
getting more power or influence you have
to ask yourself is this getting me
closer or further away from the life
that I want I've talked about how I know
exactly what my ideal day looks like
it's a Saturday where I wake up early I
work out I do a little bit of writing I
spend lots of time with my family I have
time to think I haven't signed myself up
for a bunch of pointless obligations or
phone calls or meetings I spend time
Outdoors I'm connected I'm present and
so I have to look at each opportunity
then that comes along any day
and ask myself is it getting me closer
or further away from the kind of life I
want to lead and the kind of person that
I want to be to be or to do this is a
key question that comes to us from the
great strategist John Boyd who as he
mentored young men and women in the
Pentagon would see that you kind of can
go down two paths in life there's a
person who wants to look important that
wants to achieve a high rank that wants
to be in the newspapers or on TV and
then there's the person who wants to
quietly get things done
I think it was Truman has said it's
amazing how much you can accomplish if
you don't care about who gets the credit
to be or to do is is largely about
credit do you care about accomplishments
what do you care about impact do you
care about credit or do you care about
getting things done you have to ask
yourself am I trying to be an important
person am I trying to accomplish
important things and this question is
critical to be or to do how are you
measuring your life Hillel said if I am
not for me who is then he said if I am
only for me who am I this I think is
related to the idea of to be or to do
what's motivating you is it external
accomplishments or is it making a
difference in this world yes you have to
fight for yourself you have to stand up
for yourself you get walked all over but
if all you care about is protecting
yourself if all you care about is
attention who are you I think about
someone like George Marshall who
accomplishes so much and perhaps his
greatest accomplishment is turning down
the command at Normandy he didn't want
his personal feelings to be taken into
account again to be or to do but also
who am I for and who am I yes he fought
really hard to get where he was to make
a difference but then he also knew that
ego didn't matter in the end What
mattered is the team effort there's a
great expression I heard that says if
you play for the name on the front of
the Jersey they'll remember the name on
the back what am I missing by choosing
to worry or be afraid one of my favorite
books is the gift of fear by Gavin de
Becker and he says when you worry ask
yourself what am I choosing not to see
right now right we only have so much in
the way of cognitive resources or time
or emotional uh energy how are you going
to spend it and then Often by being
anxious by being worried by taking
things personally by being afraid we're
taking our eye off the ball and so I
want you to see those emotions not just
as unpleasant but actively destructive
because they are stuff's gonna happen in
life that makes us emotional but we have
to realize that we're only compel
founding that by acting on those
emotions
are you doing your job this is a key
question when Sean Payton was suspended
from the NFL pre for a year he put up a
big picture of himself in the Saints
facility and three words so do your job
this is a thing I think it comes from
Bill Belichick but the idea is that
everyone has a job in every moment
sometimes that's a little job sometimes
it's a big job but everyone has to know
their job in an organization in life
you've got to ask yourself are you doing
it I think in the end we end up focusing
on everyone else's job than our own
because it's easier than doing our own
and that's why I like this question so
much are you doing your job and if you
aren't why not if you are good keep
doing
what is the most important thing to you
what do you actually value if you don't
know what's important how do you know
that you're putting it first and so to
me all the other questions of Life come
after you have asked and answered what
the most important thing to you is in
life if you told me I could sell 10
times as many books but it'd come at the
expense of my marriage or my
relationship with my kids I'd say screw
that right because I know the most
important thing to me is how those
things are in balance with each other
yes my work is important but it's not
the most important thing you know Seneca
talks about this idea of euthymia it
says knowing the path that you're on and
not being distracted by the paths of the
people who's crisscross yours he says
especially the people who are hopelessly
lost when you know what's important when
you know what you value when you know
where you're going it makes it easy for
you to ignore what doesn't matter can
focus on what does matter
who is this for this is a question as a
Creator you always have to know who are
you making this for I talked to so many
entrepreneurs business people creatives
who have no idea they're just making
stuff they just hope it will find an
audience they go oh this is a book for
smart people you have to know who you're
making this for you have to know your
audience you have to know the market you
have to know human beings that's why
empathy is so important who are you
making this for who are they where where
are they what do they want you have to
know who this is for so I always ask
myself they're making a video or putting
out a tweet or or writing a book screw
your hunches who is this for who are
they
does this actually matter right so many
of the things we're upset about that we
hold on to that we focus on they don't
matter not to you to anyone at all they
don't they just don't matter Marcus
Aurelius says ask yourself in every
moment is this essential this is because
most of what we do and say is not
essential he says when you eliminate the
inessential you get the double benefit
of doing the essential things better
Stephen Colbert loses his father and
several siblings in a plane crash as a
young man and he said what he took out
of this was a question from his mother
she said can you look at this in the
light of Eternity does this matter in
the big picture right because so many of
the things we trivially get upset about
that we focus on in moments of Crisis we
get real clarity about we realize they
didn't matter at all people matter your
loved ones matter doing your best
matters everything else is irrelevant
and yet that's where we focus so much of
our time and energy
will this be a live time or dead time
that's something Robert Greene asked me
when I was thinking about becoming a
writer I had like a year to kill before
I could go do and he said what's this
year going to be for you is it going to
be a lifetime or dead time for you we're
going to use every second or you're
going to sit around and be passive and
wait that came flooding back to me in
the pandemic when we went into lockdown
this is going to be a live time or dead
time what am I going to have to show for
this whether it's two weeks or two
months or two years what am I going to
have to show for this period a lifetime
treat every moment like a lifetime
because while you have it you're alive
but after it's gone it's dead now is now
can you use this time what can you use
it for if you always choose a lifetime
then you're always getting better and
you're always moving forward you're not
wasting time Seneca says it's not that
life is short it's that we waste a lot
of it we kill time as time is killing us
and the truth is you always have the
ability to make the most of this moment
so often we choose not to because we we
don't ask ourselves this question
is this who I want to be is this
representative of the person that I see
myself as that I am trying to become or
am I giving in to my lower self here am
I taking a shortcut here am I doing
something that the person that I see
myself as wouldn't do Cheryl Strait says
you're becoming who you're going to be
so you might as well not be an [ __ ]
when you do things you have to ask
yourself is this representative of my
character
of my priorities of my values of what I
said is important to me if the answer is
no you have to not do it how we do
anything is how we do everything so you
have to ask yourself this question is
this who I want to be every interaction
every situation big or small because it
adds up in the way that nothing else can
if I can give you one more question
a last question bonus question to you
what comes to us from Victor Frankel who
survives the Holocaust who writes the
amazing book man search for meaning
you know he says we ask what is the
meaning of life
but he says actually
it is life that is asking us that
question and it's our actions it's our
decisions to provide the answer
meaning is something we create from our
actions from our decisions from our
choices from who we choose to be these
are the kinds of questions that if you
ask often enough
you will provide as Viktor Franco says
the kinds of answers
that make you who you're capable of
becoming
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens I get asked all the time
what I would take if I could only take
one supplement the answer is invariably
ag-1 by athletic greens if you're
traveling if you're just busy if you're
not sure if your meals where they should
be it covers your bases with
approximately 75 vitamins minerals and
Whole Foods Source ingredients you'll be
hard-pressed to find a more nutrient
dense formula on the market it has a
multivitamin multi-mineral greens
complex probiotics and prebiotics for
gut health and Immunity formula
digestive enzymes and adaptogens you get
the idea right now athletic greens is
giving my audience a special offer on
top of their all-in-one formula which is
a free vitamin D supplement and five
free travel packs with your first
subscription purchase many of us are
deficient in vitamin D I've found that
true for myself which is usually
produced in our bodies from sun exposure
so adding a vitamin D supplement to your
daily routine is a great option for
additional immune support support your
immunity gut health and energy by
visiting athletic greens.com Tim you'll
receive up to a year's supply of vitamin
D and five free travel packs with your
subscription again that's
athleticgreens.com Tim
what follows is a clip from my interview
with the incredible Maria Popova so who
is Maria Maria Popova you can find her
on Twitter at brainpicker on Instagram
Maria
popova-p-o-p-o-v-a is a reader and a
writer who writes about what she reads
this is all a huge understatement her
website is the marginalian formerly
known as brain pickings and it is
included in the Library of Congress
permanent web Archive of culturally
valuable materials she's the author also
of figuring and the editor of a velocity
of being subtitle letters to a young
reader you can find the marginalian at
the
marginalian.org for 15 years it has
remained free and AD free and Alive
thanks to patronage from readers I am
one of her loyal readers her work is
incredibly insightful incredibly
prolific I don't know how she does it
and if this labor of love of Maria's has
made made your life more livable in the
past year or the past decade consider a
one-time or loyal donation to The
marginalian your support makes a
difference and I want to see Maria as do
millions of people continue her amazing
work for many many years to come please
enjoy
your schedule so I've I I've read of
your schedule but I'd love to hear the
current iteration of that it seems like
you you've had a fairly you have a
fairly regimented schedule which would
make sense if you're putting the number
of of hours into reading and writing
that you do so what is what is your
current day look like
well I'll answer this with a caveat the
one thing I have struggled with or tried
to solve for myself in the last few
years couple years maybe is this sort of
really delicate balance between
productivity and presence and
especially in a culture that seems to
measure our Worth or Merit or our value
through our efficiency and our earnings
and our ability to perform certain tasks
as opposed to
just the Fulfillment we feel in our own
lives and the the presence that we take
in in the day-to-day and that's
something that's become more and more
apparent to me so I'm a little bit
reluctant to discuss routine as some
sort of Holy Grail of creative process
because it's just really it's a crutch I
mean routines and rituals help us
not feel like this overwhelming
messiness of just day-to-day life would
consume us it's a control mechanism but
that's not all there is and if anything
it should be in the service of something
greater which is being present with
one's own life so with that in mind my
day is very predictable
um
I get up in the morning I meditate for
between 15 to 25 minutes before I do
anything else what time do you wake up
typically
exactly eight hours after I've gone to
bed so it varies okay I'm a huge
proponent of sleep I think
um
I when I write because what or when I
guess try to think what I do is
essentially make associations between
seemingly unrelated ideas and Concepts
and in order for that to happen you know
those associative chains need to be
firing and when I am sleep deprived I
feel like I don't have full access to my
own brain which is certainly I'm not
unique in that in any way there's
research showing that or reflexes are
severely hindered by lack of sleep we're
almost as drunk if if we sleep less than
half the amount of time we normally need
to function and I think
ours is a culture where we where we um
where our ability to get by on very
little sleep is a kind of badge honor
badge of honor that the speaks work
ethic or toughness or whatever it is but
really
it's a total profound failure of
priorities and of self-respect and I try
to sort of enact that in my own life by
being very disciplined about my sleep at
least as disciplined as about as I am
about my work because the latter is a
product of the capacities you know
cultivated by the former um so in any
case so I get up eight hours after I
have gone to bed I meditate
um I go to the gym where I do most of my
longer form reading
I get back home I have breakfast and I
start writing I usually write between
two and three articles a day and one of
them tends to be longer and when I write
I need uninterrupted time so I try to
get the longer one done earlier on in
the day when I feel much more alert so I
don't look at email or any anything
really external to the the material I'm
I'm dealing with which does require
quite a bit of research usually so it's
not like I can cut myself off on the
Internet or from other books but uh I
don't have people disruptions I guess so
anything social and then I take a a
short break I'm a Believer in sort of
pacing
um creating a sort of Rhythm where you
do very intense focused work for an
extended period and you take a short
break and then cycle back you know and
then I I deal with any sort of
admin stuff like emails and just taking
care of errands and whatnot and I resume
writing and I write my other article or
articles
through the evening I try to have some
private time
just later in the day either with
friends or with my partner or just you
know
time that is unburdened by deliberate
thought although you can never unburden
yourself from thought in general and
then usually later at night I either do
some more reading or some more writing
or a combination of the two
got it and so a number of follow-up
questions what type of meditation do you
practice currently
just guided vipassana very
very basic there's a woman named Tara
Brock who she's a mindfulness
practitioner how do you spell her last
name
b-r-a-c-h got it
and she's based out of DC and she was
trained as a cognitive psychologist then
did decades of Buddhist training and and
lived in an ashram and now she teaches
mindfulness but with a very secular lens
so
um she records her classes and she has a
podcast which is how I um
came to know her and every week she does
a one hour lecture on sort of the
philosophies and cognitive behavioral
you know wisdom of the ages and then she
does a guided meditation
um so I I use her meditations and she
has changed my life perhaps more
profoundly than anybody in my life so I
highly highly recommend her
um Tara Brock Brock yes and all her her
podcast is free she has two books out
too um she's really wonderful very
generous person I will have to check
that out and see you're listening then
you have earbuds in uh when you're or
you're listening you're listening to
audio while you meditate yes and it's
interestingly I mean she puts one out
every week but I've been using the exact
same one from the summer of 2010 it's
just one that I like and feel familiar
with and it sort of helps me get into
the Rhythm so every day I listen to the
exact summer 2010 how does that start
how would people recognize it how does
the Audio I think the title is it sounds
cheesy but it is not cheesy I think it's
called smile meditation and I'm sure she
has repeated it in various forms Through
The Years in other recordings it just
happens to be the one that I you know
have on and on my broken 3G iPhone
without any internet or cell service
which I just use as an iPod and that's
on it awesome that's a great answer
um gotta I love digging into the
specific so when you go to the gym then
uh to work out are you still using an
elliptical for that or are you are I do
Sprints time intensity intervals on the
elliptical and are you for cardio and I
do a lot of um weights and body weight
stuff too you do all right but when
you're reading is that on the elliptical
yes and what type of device if any are
you using for that reading
well I prefer electronic so I use the
Kindle app on the iPad or any PDF viewer
because I read a lot of archival stuff
but the challenge of course is that
because I read so many older books that
are out of print let alone having
digital versions that's not always
possible in case it's rarely possible
unless I'm writing about something
fairly new and so in that case I just go
there with my big Tome and my sticky
notes and pens and Sharpies and various
annotation Analog Devices and I just do
that cool all right so that that leads
perfectly into the next question which
is what is your note-taking system look
like and how do you take notes so for
instance
uh you're really good at using
um excerpts or quotations pull quotes
and I found myself asking as I was
reading this like how how are you
Gathering all this so that you can
use it later so what is your note-taking
system look like when you see in the
case of digital and in the case of hard
copy
um so with digital
um it's very simple I just highlight
passages and I write myself little notes
underneath each that are that have
acronyms that I use frequently for
certain topics or shorthand that I have
developed for myself but reading is
really or understanding really which is
what reading should be a conduit to is a
form of pattern recognition so when you
read a whole book
you kind of walk away with certain
takeaways that are thematically linked
and they don't usually occur you know
sequentially so it's not like
you walk away with one inside from the
first chapter one instead from the
second chapter it's just sort of this
pattern of the writer's thoughts that
that that permeate the entire Narrative
of the book and so
especially as you if you read as a
writer so somebody who not only needs to
walk away with that but ideally wants to
record what those patterns and themes
are that sort of reading is very
different and so what I end up doing
with analog books in particular and it's
I've sort of hacked some systems of
doing it electronically but they're
imperfect is at on the very last page of
age book which is blank usually right
before the end cover I create a an
alternate index so I basically list out
as I'm reading the topics and ideas that
that seem to be important and recurring
in that volume and then next to each of
them I start listing out the page
numbers where they occur and on those
pages I have obviously highlighted the
respective passage and I have a little
sort of sticky tab on the side so I can
find it but it's basically
an index based not on keywords which is
what a standard book index is based on
on but based on key ideas and I use that
then to sort of synthesize what those
ideas are once I'm ready to write about
the book
but on this because I'm so excited now
um so as it turns out with analog books
I do exactly literally exactly the same
thing I usually start with in front
inside cover but I create my own index
and of course they don't have to be in
order so you can sort of list yeah them
in any in my particular case in any any
order uh I also will have sort of uh two
a couple of of lines dedicated to pH and
pH just refers to phrasing so if I find
a turn of phrase or wording that I find
really oh I do that too
BL for beautiful language oh that's so
cool okay so there's that and then I
have
um
you know like Q or Q if I if they're
quotes so for instance many books will
have
uh quotes attributed to other people or
just header quotes uh in some cases and
so I'll have uh you know quotes I'll
just write that out and then colon and
then I'll list all the page numbers for
that particular sort of
category that I'm collecting in the case
of quotes So for when you're gathering
this you mentioned acronyms and uh
shorthand so besides beautiful language
what are some of the other acronyms that
you use oh they wouldn't make sense
they're just very private it's like too
long to get into what they stand for
instantly my own system is there one
other example that you just just if you
could indulge me
one that is I guess not so much about
the contents of that passage as as about
its purpose is LJ which is I have a
little sort of Labor of Love side
project called literary jukebox right
sure I've seen it it's yeah it's it's
awesome oh thank you but yeah so I do
these tearing the passages from
literature with a thematically matched
song and so sometimes when as I'm
reading a book I would come across a
passage that I think would be great for
that and maybe a song comes to mind and
so I would put LJ next to it but I want
to go back to what you said about the
external quotes I guess the author
quoting another work I think those are
actually really important and that goes
back to your question about how I find
what to read and
I Mark those types of things so for the
for the annotations that are specific to
that particular book all of my sticky
tab notes are on the side of the of the
pages but when it there's an external
quote something referencing another work
I put a tab at the very top with the
letter F which stands for find if I am
not familiar with the word the work or
just no letter if I just want to flag a
quote from something else that I know of
and I think that's actually very
important because
the the the
phenomenon itself not my annotations of
it because literature is really and I
say this all the time it is the original
internet so all of those references and
citations and Illusions even they're
essentially hyperlinks that that author
placed to another work
um and that way if you follow those you
go into this magnificent Rabbit Hole
where you start out with something that
you're already enjoying and liking but
follow these tangential references to
other works that perhaps you would not
have come across that way I mean
directly and in a way
it's a way to push oneself out of the
filter bubble in a very incremental way
and I've often found amazing older books
that were you know five or six hyperlink
references removed from something I was
reading which led me to something else
which led me something else which led me
to this great other thing
um so I think that's that's kind of a
beautiful practice
yeah it's uh the the Serendipity of it
is uh so beautiful when it works out and
I'll I'll uh
give a confession this is really
embarrassing but uh you know since no
one's listening
we came across Seneca so Seneca the
younger who's had probably more impact
on my life than any other writer
uh originally because there I I was
perusing a number of anthologies on
minimalism and simplicity and Seneca
kept on popping up quote Seneca quote
Seneca and because it was always one
word like Madonna
or and this is going to be really
embarrassing or like Sitting Bull I
assumed that Seneca was a Native
American Elder of some type for probably
a good lovely actually I I assumed he
was a Native American Elder for a
probably a good year or two before I
realized he was a Roman and I was like
man first you got to do your homework
pal like you gotta dig in and then at
that point is when I really sort of
jumped off the cliff into all a lot of
his writings which I've I still to this
day revisit on an almost Revisited
um
his um the shortness of life oh so good
so is this perhaps the best Manifesto
and I had paid this modern word
um sort of buzzword but I used it
intentionally so the best Manifesto for
our current struggle with this very
notion of you know productivity versus
presence and how much are we really
mistaking the doing for the being you
know and and it's amazing that somebody
wrote this Millennia ago before there
was internet before there was the things
we call distractions today and and yet
he writes about the exact same things
just in a different form
yeah the exact same things and the way
that uh if I'm trying to use Seneca as a
gateway drug into philosophy I I won't
use the p word first of all with most
people because philosophy smacks of I
think it calls to mind for a lot of
people the sort of haughty pompous uh
college student in um
uh
Goodwill Hunting in the bar scene who's
like reciting you know Shakespeare
without giving uh any type of yeah I
completely disagree no actually I I
agree with the notion that those are its
connotations today and people have a
resistance but I think that's all the
more reason to use it heavily and to use
it intelligently and to reclaim it and
to get people to understand that
philosophy whatever form it takes is the
only way to figure out how to live the
other thing else that we take away from
anything is a set of philosophies
essentially I agree no I totally agree
so but I usually if I'm going to lead
people there I try to to to lure them
lure them in with with Seneca because I
think he's he's very easy to read
compared to a lot of say at least the
stoics uh or or that's actually not even
fair compared to a lot of philosophers
who who have been translated from Greek
I'll uh most of his writing I believe
was translated from Latin which tends to
be just an easier jump from English so
um it's very easy to read and I what I
tell people is you know start off with
some of his letters and you'll find that
you could just as easily replace these
Roman names like lucillus and and so on
with like Bob and Jane or you know pick
your contemporary name if uh of choice
and it they're all as relevant now as
they were then
I'm Cal Newport I'm a professor of
computer science at Georgetown
University
where my research focuses on the theory
of distributed algorithms I'm also
however a New York Times best-selling
author
who writes about the intersection of
Technology productivity and the quest to
live and work deeply in an increasingly
distracted world
now you might know me from some of my
recent books
such as deep work digital minimalism and
a world without email you might also
know me from my writing for the New
Yorker where I am on the contributor
staff
the clip you're about to hear comes from
my podcast deep questions with Cal
Newport now on this show I take written
questions and voice calls from my
readers they ask questions about the
various Theory I write about and I help
them put it into practice in the messy
reality of their actual lives
if you like what you hear you can
subscribe to the podcast deep questions
with Cal Newport on all of the standard
podcast platforms if you prefer video
you can go to youtube.com
calnewport media there you will find
full episodes as well as clips of
popular questions and segments all right
so anyways here comes the clip I hope
you enjoy it
today I want to do my first
core idea video deep dive I should say
my first core idea Deep dive and the
topic I want to do it on is
time management
so my goal here is to give a brief
summary of my thinking about time
management
and what that's going to consist of is
let me Define for you what I mean by
time management
let me give you
the three principles
in my writing and on this podcast we
always talk about that any good time
management system should probably
satisfy and then I will briefly talk
through my particular system
which we can think of as one example of
a time management system that satisfies
these principles you can do something
else but so you see what a real fully
fledged time management system that
satisfies these principles look like and
then I'm going to have a bonus fourth
principle I want to talk about
that debatably is not really about time
management it lives right outside time
management but it's related so I'm going
to talk about that briefly at the end so
that is my agenda for this core idea
discussion on time management
so let's start what do I mean by time
management for me
at least in the context of this
discussion I'm thinking about work
so time management in work
the way you deal with your time outside
of work is a little bit different and so
I'm going to put that aside
and in the context of work
I'm going to Define time management to
be whatever philosophy process systems
or rules that you deploy to make
decisions about what you're going to do
right now with your time
how do you figure out it's 12 26 on a
Friday what do I do next
in the end that's what a time management
system is a way to help you answer that
question in as useful a manner as
possible
now everyone who works has some sort of
time management system they're using if
you don't know what it's called if you
can't tell me the details of it if
you've never thought about that it's
just a really bad one probably but you
still have one one way or the other
you're making these decisions the
question is just how do we want to make
these decisions what is going to work
better so I'm going to give you
the three properties I think any good
time management system should have
I love alliteration
long time listeners the podcast know
this I love C's in my alliteration as
long time listeners of this podcast know
so I name the three Key Properties here
with three C's capture
configure control
let's talk about these each briefly in
the abstract and I'll tell you about my
system that satisfies these number one
capture
I believe a good professional time
management system
needs to have some place in which you
store
all the information that's important to
making decisions about what you need to
be doing and what you should be doing
that is trusted it's a place that you
are going to look at things that go in
there will not be forgotten these ideas
get out of your head and into a system
so you're not wasting brain Cycles on
trying to remember or keep fresh stuff
that you need to do
now in the context of tasks
we can give credit to this idea to David
Allen so David Allen and his seminal
post computer time management book and I
mean that very specifically because as
I've written about before time
management goes through big evolution so
post computers computer networks and
email time management went through a big
revolution David Allen was there at the
beginning
he had this idea of full capture where
he said all of your tasks should be in a
trusted system that you review regularly
not in your head he actually adapted
that idea from a previous business
thinker named Dean Atchison
unrelated to President Truman Secretary
of State same name different person who
had first developed I believe in the
1970s this notion of full capture and
David Allen expanded it so that's really
the core of this
and David Allen's articulation of full
capture said don't waste mental energy
remembering things have it in a system
so your brain can be clear to actually
focus on working
this also reduces a lot of stress
because your brain gets stressed when
it's worried about forgetting things you
need to do
I generalize capture though beyond what
Alan talks about
in addition to each of your commitments
being somewhere you trust
I want your plans to also be somewhere
your trust so any thinking you've done
about what you're working on on all
sorts of different time scales
that should be written down somewhere
you trust and review regularly as well I
think that's often overlooked but the
planning process of what's going on how
do I want to get my work done what needs
to be done this semester what do I have
to get done this week to hit this goal
that's a really important part of time
management I don't want that all in your
head
that also gets captured
all right second property
configure
all right this is a a Twist that I've
become
increasingly a loud advocate for which
is
care more about how you actually
organize this information that you're
capturing
I think you really need to think through
once I have this information written
down somewhere
where do I put it how do I organize it
is it in categories is it broken up by
roll
uh equally important getting the
relevant information Consolidated I'm
really big on this so not only do you
have a a really smart Organization for
all the stuff on your plate
you're also gathering in one place all
the relevant information
you're not searching through your email
inbox to try to remember what does this
mean and where are we and what do I owe
this person I'm supposed to get back to
Derek about the program codes what does
that mean let me go through my inbox now
all that should be in one place
so these are our two goals with with
organize
uh a that the information is organized
well where what you want to happen here
what you want to have happen here is
that you can very quickly get the
Gestalt of what's on your plate what's
due what's not who you're waiting to
hear back from the information is put
aside in such a way that it's not just a
list with a hundred things and two all
the relevant information is there
I'm not scrambling around to figure out
what I need to know to do this thing
all the information is there
all right control
the third property of a good prime time
management system
control says instead of being reactive
in your decisions about what you want to
do with your time and by reactive I mean
just saying okay it's 12 23 on Friday
um what do I want to do next I don't
know let me see what seems relevant let
me look at my uh let me look at my inbox
let me look at Slack maybe I'll look at
a to-do list and try to choose something
off of it
control says don't be reactive don't
wait till you get to the moment to say
what should I do next
instead be proactive make a plan for
your time in advance that makes the most
of the time that you actually have
available so you think ahead you look at
the time you have available and you say
what do I want to do with this
I'm planning the whole picture at once
I'm not waiting till the moment to say
what happens next
now on the podcast
I talk often about doing this control
at multiple time scales you'll hear me
talk about multi-scale planning this is
where that actually applies and what I
recommend is that you should be doing
this type of planning on three time
scales quarterly weekly daily
so quarterly
you have a plan
for what you want to try to get done
that quarter what's important what are
the big projects you're working on uh
there could even be daily work that you
want to really emphasize like look I got
to get my cold calls up
so every Monday Wednesday Friday I spend
the first hour doing cold calls whatever
it is but you're making this plan for
the quarter
looking ahead at the quarter is just a
busy quarter not a big quarter what are
the big deadlines this quarter is there
a huge Trade Fair halfway through it
that means the first half of the quarter
has to be really focused on preparing
for that trade of Trade Fair you're
looking at the whole picture of the
quarter and at this pretty big
granularity coming up with a plan
every week
you then look at that quarterly plan and
produce a plan for the week ahead of you
now you're doing weekly planning
and when you're doing weekly planning uh
what you really want to do is get a
sense of what's going to happen which
day
and then finally you get down to the
Daily scale
where you say what am I actually doing
during the hours of the day
so we're in weekly planning you're
looking at what am I going to do the
different days of this week a daily
planning you're saying here's my day
of a meeting here I have a call here I
have two meetings here here's a time
that's for you what do I want to do
during that time so multi-scale planning
I think is the right way to think about
control you're giving your time a job as
opposed to asking in the moment what
should I do next
all right so I think any good time
management system should do capture
configure control
let me talk briefly about my per
specific instantiation of these
properties what my time management
system looks like at the moment
so for capture
there is where I actually store
the things I need to do and I use Trello
which is a task board Software System so
it gives you a visual metaphor for cards
on a board arranged vertically in
columns I use Trello to keep track of
tasks and commitments and I use Google
Docs
they keep track of plans
the plans I have about various things so
trellos where all my tasks are Google
Docs are where my my plans live so
that's where in multi-scale planning my
quarterly plan lives uh
that's where other plans live Jesse and
I for example have a Google doc where we
we have our plans for the podcast
Etc
Trello for tasks
Google docs for plans
in addition to the storage systems you
have to have the capture tool so the
tools you use to capture things during
the day on the Fly that will then get
later moved into those storage systems
now for me I use two main ones
I have my time block planner
I am in a lucky situation where I was
able to design and publish my own
planner so you can obviously find out
more about that at timeblockplanner.com
but that planner has uh for every day a
page in which you can capture stuff
so I capture stuff right in that planner
on my computer I also have a text file
on my desktop
I call it working memory Dot txt
because I think of it as like an
expansion of my actual
working memory
and I use that when I'm on my computer
to capture things especially when I'm
cleaning out my email
I can just type much faster than I can
write and I capture all sorts of notes
in this document I work through ideas on
the document it really is like an
extension of my working memory so a lot
gets captured in there if I'm in a
meeting on Zoom
things are popping up I have to do I'm
writing it probably right there in that
working memory.txt at the end of every
day I do a shutdown
my planner even has a box I checked it
says shut down complete that indicates
I've done my shutdown as part of that
shutdown process
I looked through everything in that
planner everything in working memory.txt
and I get it into one of those more
stable systems goes on the Trello or I
update my Google doc
so those things get pushed back down to
zero they're temporary tools to capture
and then they get moved into the more
stable systems
the one addendum I should add there is
the calendar obviously some of these
things are appointments so that goes
right to the calendar all right
configure
I mentioned I use Trello for my task the
way I actually use Trello is I have a
separate board for each of my different
professional roles
I keep a separate board as a writer a
separate board for example as a teacher
which I keep as a separate board as a
researcher
Etc
those are then split up in the columns
there's a few standard columns that
every one of these boards have I
typically have a column where I put
tasks on there that's called to be
processed
or it's a pretty complicated thing I
need to do and I don't quite understand
all the details of it but I don't want
to keep track of it in my head but also
you know it's five o'clock and I'm
shutting down I don't have time to spend
20 minutes figuring out what does this
mean
like what are the actual actions here so
I'll just throw that in the 2B process
column I usually have a column on each
of these boards for waiting to hear back
from
so if I've sent someone a note
and I need information from them and
that information is critical for me to
keep making progress I like to put a
card
on my Trello board under waiting to hear
back it says here's what I'm waiting to
hear back from and here's what I'm going
to do once I get that information I
don't want to remember that in my head
so I put it on there I typically have a
column for things I'm working on this
week and I'll typically have a column
for if they're specifically persistent
initiatives within that role
I'll give it its own column so I can
really quickly see for this thing I'm
working on
what are all the different things that
need to be done
so as a researcher there might be a
column for a paper we're preparing for
publication in my administrative role at
Georgetown there might be a column for a
search committee that I'm on here's the
relevant tasks
the time that I really get into and
clean this up and look at it and move
things around and check in on it is when
I do my weekly plan
so once a week as part of my commitment
to configure
I really go through these systems and I
update it
once a week when I'm building my weekly
plan
is also when I'm reviewing the Google
Docs that capture these other types of
plans that are going on and update them
and remind myself what's on them so the
weekly scale is when I'm really
getting my hands dirty throughout the
week I'm just throwing stuff into here
at the end of each day but each week I
really go in and clean things up
all right finally is control I already
talked about multi-scale planning I
think is the best way to do control you
could do it other ways but I do for me
it's semester instead of quarterly but
semester weekly daily planning semester
plans in a Google doc
weekly plan I actually type it up in a
text document and print it out
and I keep it with me in the back of my
time block planner so that's how and
I'll update it and reprint it as I need
to throughout the week and then for my
daily plan I'm time blocking like I
talked about here's my day let me block
off everything on my calendar here's the
time that remains what do I want to do
during that time
well let me look at my weekly plan to
remind myself of what my big picture
plan is for this day and then I'm
blocking off actual hours of time and
saying here's what I'm doing here here's
what I'm doing there
and I fill in all that information I do
that right on my time block planner but
you can do this in any type of notebook
there's a whole video at my site
timeblockplanner.com that walks through
the details of how time blocking works
so that is how I do uh the daily piece
you put those all together there's my
commitment to control
all right so stepping back capture
configure control you do those three
things
you're going to be making smart
decisions
about what you want to be doing with
your time professionally
now I know people get concerned they say
well I might be injecting too much
structure into my life and this is going
to make my work life more rigid and I'll
be less creative
I call nonsense and all of that
just because you're in control of
everything doesn't mean you need to
schedule every seven minutes of your
time like a crazy person
I mean you can when you're in control
your time you can now start to make
decisions like
Thursday afternoon starting at 12 I want
to do no work I'm going to go to the
woods and just think about this problem
I'm working on
when you're doing capture configure
control you can do that with confidence
because you know what's on your plate
you've cleared out that time you know
things aren't being forgotten
you made sure that you had time on
Wednesday to catch up on things people
need to hear about Thursday because
you're in control you can aim that
control at more breaks more free time
more creativity less stress
you can significantly like a lot of my
listeners do reduce the amount of time
it takes for you to get your normal
workload done
because you're in complete control of
things move it into certain days and
keep whole days free to basically do
Phantom part-time jobs there's a lot you
can do that makes your life more
interesting and creative
and less stressful
once you have an intentional way of
making these decisions about what do I
want to do next with my time
all right now I promised you a bonus
property that
arguably has to do with time management
arguably it's something different so
I'll just mention it briefly
and that is constrain
so circling this whole idea
is how you figure out
what gets on your plate to be managed in
the first place
and how you actually manage that work
now I'm just going to plant the seed
here because this is a bigger
conversation but
we need to be very careful about how we
decide what we say yes to and what we
say no to
we would really like to avoid the
situation where we have so much work on
our plate that yeah we can control it
and be organized about it but we still
don't have enough time to get it done we
want to avoid that situation so having
clear rules in place about how do I
decide what I let on my plate that's
really important
processes is the second thing that I
think is really important when it comes
to constraining
you know figuring out how do I want to
do this work
the stuff I let on my plate can I put a
process in place that will reduce the
footprint this has on my schedule
there's a lot of different things this
can mean and again because we're just
seed planting here I'm just going to
very briefly skim the surface but there
may be automation you're doing here you
know what we have to produce this same
client report every week I don't want to
just send emails back and forth and kind
of figure it out at the last minute here
is our process for doing it and you
figure out a whole process that's the
same thing the same things happen at the
same times every week you can rely on it
you've taken that burden off of your
planning system to have to figure out
from scratch
for small questions and back and forth
you might push that all towards office
hours
three days a week for one hour well
publicized I'm in my office Zoom is on
come to that office hours if you have a
small question for me come to that
office hours if there's a little bit of
information you need come to that office
hours if there's something we can figure
out in two minutes of back and forth
and when people bother you with the
email or slack like hey what are we
doing again about this or can explain to
me again what this thing means to say
yeah come to my office hours
these type of processes are all about
reducing what it is that you actually do
have to manage with your capture
configure control system you want to
simplify that simplify what's on your
plate simplify how the things around
your plate are executed the easier you
can make
the planning version of yourself's job
the better you're going to do at your
actual job
all right so let me summarize it there
that is my thinking on this core idea of
time management
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
for me every Friday that provides a
little more soul of fun before the
weekend and five bullet Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest
things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
I've somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do it could include
favorite articles that I've read and
that I've shared with my close friends
for instance and it's very short it's
just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend so
if you want to receive that check it out
just go to four hourwork.com that's for
ourworkweek.com all spelled out and just
drop in your email and you will get the
very next one and if you sign up I hope
you enjoyed
this episode is brought to you by Maui
Nui venison wildly delicious venison
Maui Nui is one of my favorite things on
the entire planet it has been for quite
a while I've been eating Maui Nui
venison for now the past three plus
years and there's no going back my
pantry and freezers are full of it I
restock every month why would I do this
one if I combine Maui Nui venison with
even a little exercise I dropped body
fat unbelievably quickly and axis deer
have roughly two percent body fat it's
incredibly lean two it's very tender not
gamey at all tastes delicious and it's
one of the most nutrient dense Meats on
the planet I would go so far as to say
it is the most nutrient dense meat I
have ever found because of the rich
volcanic soils remarkable plant
diversity and so on including wild
grazing so I literally 10 minutes ago
just finished eating some leftovers of
ground accessed ear this is Maui venison
with some canned chili just organic
chili beans and so on that I put into a
pan and cooked for 10 minutes and I
would rather eat that than a 500 meal in
New York City honestly it makes me
happier on a deep level to eat this and
it makes me healthier on a fundamental
level so number three ethically I feel
great about Maui Nui protein access deer
are an invasive species on Maui where
their population needs to be managed in
order to protect vulnerable ecosystems I
think the number that was introduced
well I was perhaps maybe 60 or in 1959
something like that and unmanaged that
population could grow to I think it's
200 000 within the next 20 years so
using stress-free harvesting methods
Maui Nui prevents environmental
destruction caused by access to your
overpopulation which literally looks
like wildfire damage from helicopter so
back to the story I love this stuff that
much should be clear I eat it all the
time I use their dog treats for Molly I
use their broth which is second to none
in terms of nutritional profile now we
know these fresh venison is a nearly
daily go-to for me both as a supplement
to my daily diet that's broth jerks
snacks Etc that I mentioned and through
main courses like last night via their
fresh meat subscription program and the
cuts are all spectacular leg medallions
are one of my favorites I fell in love
with this company so much and the
husband and wife co-founders behind it
that I ended up investing and that is a
huge Rarity especially with this type of
company remarkably Maui Nui has now
nearly stabilized Maui's access to your
population that's been the goal all
along which means the door to one of the
most exclusive proteins on the market
will soon be closed the list of people
waiting for invitations to become a
fresh subscriber is long that's not BS
that is the case there's a long wait
list which is why I am very excited to
offer you guys my listeners Tim Ferris
show listeners an exclusive opportunity
to bypass the waitlist to cut the line
and get instant access to one of the few
remaining subscriptions you can secure
your subscription by visiting Maui Nui
venison.com Tim that's Maui
[Music]
m-a-u-i-n-u-i-nui venison.com Tim you
need to have the slash Tim to bypass the
line if you're already on the wait list
and you go to this link you will get
immediate access so Maui news
venison.com now we know we must stop
offering subscriptions at only 8 000
subscribers when the access to your
population will have reached equilibrium
so you must act fast to grab one of the
remaining spots so subscribe today at
Maui news venison.com Tim one more time
that's Maui Nui venison.com Tim and the
race goes to the Swift
this episode is brought to you by eight
sleep my God am I in love with eight
sleep good sleep is the Ultimate Game
Changer more than 30 percent of
Americans struggle with sleep and I'm a
member of that sad group temperature is
one of the main causes of poor sleep and
heat has always been my Nemesis I've
suffered for decades tossing and turning
throwing blankets off putting them back
on and repeating Ad nauseam but now I am
falling asleep in record time faster
than ever why because I'm using a simple
device called the Pod Pro cover by
aidsleep it's the easiest and fastest
way to sleep at the perfect temperature
it pairs Dynamic cooling and heating
with biometric tracking to offer the
most advanced but most user-friendly
Solution on the market I pulled all of
you guys on social media about the best
tools for Sleep enhancing sleep and
eight sleep was by far and away the
crowd favorite I mean people were just
raving fans of this so I used it and
here we are add the Pod Pro cover to
your current mattress and start sleeping
as cool as 55 degrees Fahrenheit or as
hot as 110 degrees Fahrenheit it also
splits your bed in half so your partner
can choose a totally different
temperature my girlfriend runs hot all
the time she doesn't need cooling she
loves the Heat and we can have our own
bespoke temperatures on either side
which is exactly what we're doing now
for me and for many people the result
eight sleep users fall asleep up to 32
percent faster reduce sleep
interruptions by up to 40 and get more
restful sleep overall I can personally
attest to this because I track it in all
sorts of ways it's the total solution
for enhanced recovery so you can take on
the next day feeling refreshed and good
news eight sleep has launched the next
generation of the Pod the new pod 3
enables more accurate sleep and health
tracking with twice the number of
sensors it's just a smoother better
experience that delivers you the best
sleep on Earth at least that has been
true for me simply add this to existing
mattress and you're all set it is not
magic but sometimes it does feel like it
it just works so go to atesleep.com Tim
and save 250 on the Pod cover that's
eightsleep.com Tim all spelled out
e-i-g-h-t-h-sleep.com Tim eight sleep
currently ships within the US Canada the
UK select countries in the EU and
Australia you can also find the link in
this episode's description
[Applause]